hacia un puerto como este se dirigen los
desechos
desechos importados de europa el reino
unido italia bélgica alemania o incluso
francia llegan por barcos a los puertos
turcos donde los empresarios los compran
en forma de bolas de papel metal o
plástico
esta empresa ubicada cerca de la ciudad
de bursa recicla el plástico compra la
mitad de sus existencias en la unión
europea' la transforma en bolas y luego
las revende hasta tres veces más caras
por demandas
nuestras instalaciones pueden producir
el mejor plástico porque tenemos los
mejores sistemas de clasificación y los
mejores sistemas de reciclaje
en el código de barras que ven ahí es
propio del producto todos nuestros
productos reciclados tienen esa marca de
esterházy etc
desde que china le puso fin a las
importaciones de desechos en 2018
turquía se convirtió en el primer
destino de los desechos europeos
principalmente de plástico de 4000
toneladas al mes en 2016
turquía pasó a 48 mil 500 toneladas
mensuales en promedio tres años después
pero no todo se recicla estas imágenes
demuestran que algunos desechos europeos
terminan en vertederos salvajes cuando
no son quemados en el lugar
cuando uno se interesa por el
funcionamiento del sector no se da
cuenta de que todo está muy desordenado
en mi control
una gran cantidad de los desechos que
llegan no son reciclables en control
algunas profesionales del sector
seleccionan lo que les interesa y verán
el resto de los salvajes
tarjeta itv
el resultado los desechos no reciclados
contaminan el suelo el aire y el agua la
costa sur del país está bañada por la
parte más contaminada del mediterráneo
después de nuestra investigación
efectivamente nos dimos cuenta de que la
región estaba muy contaminada por el
plástico incluso tres o cuatro veces más
contaminada que otras regiones del
mediterráneo por micropartículas y
pedazos de plástico
según greenpeace la reglamentación del
sector en turquía no es muy estricta ni
eficaz
existe una legislación para regular la
importación en turquía pero
desafortunadamente no es suficiente la
gestión debe ser mejorada y la
transparencia debe ser necesaria
la ong le pide al gobierno ponerle un
término a la importación y hacer énfasis
en la clasificación de los desechos
domésticos en el país hoy en día sólo el
10 por ciento de los desechos turcos son
reciclados
y 7 no logramos clasificar nuestros
propios desechos entonces no podemos
recuperar la materia prima es por eso
que el sector del reciclaje depende del
plástico que llega del extranjero
necesitamos implementar medidas de apoyo
para facilitar la clasificación
actualmente no existe ningún sistema de
clasificación a nivel municipal o
nacional sólo hay unos 500.000
clasificadores que recorren las calles
del país en busca de materiales para
vender aquí estoy recogiendo hierro ya
donde lleva todo esto después a la
planta de reciclaje a un depósito nos
compran los materiales porque las cuánto
vale un kilo de plástico y un dólar
este hombre dice que a veces trabaja
desde las 6 de la mañana hasta la
medianoche por un sueldo de 5 dólares en
los días buenos una situación que le
llama la atención al partido verde turco
recién conformado y con dificultades
para movilizar la opinión sobre el tema
ambiental si se hace una encuesta en la
calle de todas las personas contestarán
sin duda que son sensibles a la causa
ecológica dirán si yo cuido el medio
ambiente me gusta la naturaleza pero en
turquía la causa ambiental es más
entendida como algo personal cada quien
buscando soluciones de manera individual
para cambiar los hábitos será necesaria
la educación inversiones costosas a
nivel municipal y sobre todo tiempo
entre tanto turquía prefiere generar
ganancias con los desechos de los demás
además de las consecuencias que esto
tiene para su propio medioambiente